[Música]
porque vamos a hablar hoy de londres lo
cierto es que el otro día fui al cine a
ver la última película del diario de
bridget jones si se lo que estáis
pensando pero mi novia quería ir y yo
soy una persona muy obediente el caso es
que esta película está ambientada en
londres y hubo una cosa que me llamó
mucho la atención fijaros en los
rascacielos que se ven en el fondo esto
no estaba en la primera película de
bridget jones que está rodada hace unos
10 años es decir si os dais cuenta el
skyline londinense ha cambiado una
barbaridad en sólo una década y esto es
llamativo porque no hablamos de un país
que esté en pleno crecimiento como china
o dubai
[Música]
así que cuando llegue a casa me puse a
buscar qué había pasado en londres
últimamente y es flipante porque si
miramos la economía de reino unido en
los últimos diez años no vamos a ver
ningún crecimiento espectacular pero sin
embargo londres es otro mundo de hecho a
día de hoy ya es la cuarta capital que
más rápido está creciendo casi al mismo
nivel que dubai y su población ha
crecido un 50% en sólo 20 años
pensar que en un continente como europa
donde casi todos los países están
perdiendo población
londres ha sumado 3 millones de
habitantes así de repente de golpe como
por arte de magia en el mundo financiero
londres es hoy en día más importante que
la mismísima nueva york' preguntaréis
qué ha pasado en esta ciudad cómo se
explica este milagro económico hoy os lo
vamos a explicar
[Música]
inmigración reino unido siempre ha sido
un país de inmigrantes y lógicamente el
principal destino de todos estos nuevos
ciudadanos es la capital
londres sin embargo en los últimos diez
años esta inmigración se ha disparado y
esto nos lo explica gabriel de fermán
que es un politólogo español que lleva
tres años viviendo en esta ciudad hola
fonseca pues llevo más de seis años ya
viven dando andrés la verdad que el
tiempo vuela y bueno con la ampliación
de la unión europea año 2004 y 2007 hubo
más de 12 países que se unieron a
europea entre ellos bulgaria rumanía eso
supuso un gran movimiento giratorio de
europa del este asia reino unido y sobre
todo desde polonia
[Música]
aún más a esto habría que añadir la
inmigración proveniente de españa italia
y portugal los que me encuentro yo que
venían después del claves del 2008 y
sobre esto además está toda la
inmigración que proviene de la
commonwealth que son países como la
india pakistán canadá o australia la
mayor parte de los inmigrantes europeos
tienen una alta cualificación por
ejemplo en londres a día de hoy hay más
de un millón seiscientos mil empleos de
alta cualificación mientras que en nueva
york' solamente alcanza un poquito más
de un millón cien mil trabajos
cualificados esto significa que además
de cubrir los trabajos que los
británicos no quieren hacer los
inmigrantes europeos también son
contratados en trabajos de alta
cualificación y emprender sus propios
negocios en el sector servicios como
puede ser el tecnológico o el gerencial
tomás abrió su empresa de marketing
cuatro años después de llegar de
varsovia y ahora da trabajo a seis
personas cuatro de las cuales son
británicas
pero no sólo hay que ver las empresas
desde un punto de vista económico o de
creación de empleo el hecho de que haya
gente bien formada significa más bares
más fiestas más exposiciones y más
eventos culturales es decir todas esas
cosas que hacen que una ciudad sea cool
por ejemplo fuera de perú cuál sería el
mejor restaurante de comida peruana del
mundo pues según todas las guías
gastronómicas es el ceviche que donde
está efectivamente en la capital
británica como esther fonseca donde es
tiene un atractivo único ya que es un
referente mundial en la gastronomía
aunque resulte sorprendente además de
serlo en la cultura y desde tenía
[Música]
y bueno donde también tiene muchas cosas
que ofrecer además de tener una economía
dinámica unas instituciones fuertes
también ofrecen unos salarios altos eso
hizo que muchos de nosotros que vivíamos
en españa italia grecia si pudiéramos
elegir
londres como destino porque además tras
la crisis financiera de 2008 los
mercados laborales se contrajeron mucho
por lo que muchos nos vimos forzados a
irnos si queríamos seguir nuestra
vocación esto es lo que muchos
economistas están empezando a llamar ya
el efecto red que significa que cuanta
más gente y más empresas haya en un
sitio concreto más incentivos hay para
que entren nuevos inmigrantes y creen
más empresas aún
para que os hagáis una idea desde el año
londres está generando una media de 1000
startups tecnológicas cada año pero
esperad porque todavía hay más
la city londinense todos estos
rascacielos que veis aquí están
concentrados en un área que apenas ocupa
poco más de un kilómetro cuadrado a este
barrio se le llama la city de londres es
decir que por un lado tenemos en londres
que todos conocemos y luego está en
londres londres en londres de verdad que
es como un país aparte dentro del reino
de hecho normalmente decimos que gran
bretaña es la unión de cuatro naciones
inglaterra escocia gales e irlanda del
arte verdad bueno en realidad no es del
todo cierto porque habría que añadir
esta quinta que es londres la city de
londres que tiene su propio alcalde y
sus propias leyes
-usted y stockton y la city es el centro
financiero de gran bretaña alrededor de
7000 personas viven en la city pero cada
día 300.000 acuden a trabajar en sus
bancos y empresas es decir que el
alcalde de londres es este señor que
vemos aquí que se llama sadik khan pero
sin embargo el lord alcalde de la city
de londres es este otro que vemos aquí
que se llama
jeffrey monte manos y una de las
particularidades del sistema político de
londres londres es que no solamente
votan las personas residentes sino que
también tienen derecho a votar las
empresas establecidas en este lugar por
ejemplo unilever tiene su sede fiscal en
la city londinense y por eso cuando hay
elecciones
unilever puede votar
y os preguntaréis valdría lo mismo el
voto de unilever y el de otras empresas
más pequeñas pues no porque dependiendo
del número de trabajadores que tenga
esta empresa registrados en la city
tendrán derecho a votar más o menos
dueños
por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música de fordo tengo mis
un grupo de rock de irlanda que nos ha
mandado su música si os gusta buscarles
en los enlaces de la descripción
[Música]
y os preguntaréis es entonces la city un
paraíso fiscal pues la respuesta es que
no en reino unido los impuestos son muy
parecidos en todas las regiones y
concretamente el impuesto de sociedades
que es el que afecta a las empresas es
igual en todo el país ahora bien es
cierto que la city tiene unas normas muy
favorables para los negocios por ejemplo
las normas de urbanismo de la city
londinense son muchísimo más laxas que
las del resto de londres y por eso es
por lo que en estas zonas se concentran
todos los rascacielos que veíamos en la
película de ficción
ahora bien
tiene un rol mucho más interesante que
todo eso porque este lord alcalde del
que hablábamos antes tiene como
principal cometido viajar por todo el
mundo ofreciendo las maravillosas
ventajas que tiene londres para la
inversión
el norte alcalde viajará a indonesia
para asegurar que londres y reino unido-
continúan siendo un socio preferente
para servicios financieros y
profesionales es decir que londres tiene
su propio departamento de marketing para
atraer a todas las empresas del mundo
en tracción de sectores eeuu tiene su
poder económico dividido en distintas
ciudades por ejemplo la política está en
washington dc si lo que te interesa es
el mundo financiero te tendrías que ir a
nueva york si quieres industria y
automoción te vas a detroit si quieres
entretenimiento y tecnología te vas a
los ángeles o san francisco lo mismo
ocurre en alemania donde tenemos a
berlín munich y frankfurt en españa
estaría madrid y barcelona mientras que
reino unido solamente tiene donde elegir
las demás ciudades no pueden competir
con esta megalópolis
londres es un referente en el ámbito
tecnológico político económico social
artístico cultural y la moda eso
significa que para él esta es una idea
que londres genera el 22 por ciento de
la riqueza que se genera en todo el país
esos 65 millones de personas londres es
una ciudad única y no sólo por el 'big
ben' xusticia en chips y los pubs google
mantiene sede aquí los mejores
intelectuales vienen a las charlas y
clases en las universidades londinenses
como por ejemplo los músculos económicos
en número de ciclistas se ha triplicado
por tres en los últimos 15 años candem
tiene música de calidad para dar y tomar
estamos resumiendo que londres tiene
muchos atractivos
[Música]
a todo esto hay que sumarle un factor
muy importante y es que reinó unido-
siempre ha tenido muy buenas relaciones
comerciales con eeuu y esto no es porque
tenga ningún acuerdo de libre comercio
simplemente es que en los dos países
tienen el inglés como lengua materna y
eso quieras que no ayuda mucho para el
comercio si a eso le sumas el hecho de
ser parte de la unión europea
tienes que londres es la ciudad perfecta
para cualquier empresa estadounidense
que quiera abrir mercado en europa
y la pregunta es afectará el break si
tal crecimiento de londres porque una
cosa está clara aunque una mayoría de
los británicos votará a favor de salirse
de la unión europea la inmensa mayoría
de los londinenses estaba a favor de
quedarse y vosotros qué pensáis podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre si alguien
quiere profundizar más en este tema
encontrará varios links en la
descripción si os ha gustado el vídeo
dadle a like y no olvidéis que
publicamos nuevos vídeos todas las
semanas así que no os perdáis ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y suscribiros
si no lo habéis hecho todavía nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]